40 grados supuestamente se va a acercar
el termómetro mañana en toda francia
sobre todo en el oeste del país en el
sur y el oeste en general y es una ola
que como sabemos viene de áfrica del
magreb del norte de áfrica que ya pasó
por españa o está afectando a ese país y
está llegando obviamente a francia a las
explicaciones como siempre el cambio
climático lo que más preocupa a mete
ojos el organismo que rige el clima aquí
en francia es que el invierno y la
primavera también han sido con muy poca
lluvia muy poco húmedos y por lo tanto
una ola de calor lo que implica también
es un riesgo un riesgo de incendio bueno
como usted puede ver causamos furor aquí
en la torre eiffel la gente quiere
aparecer en france24 así que son olas
que se repiten cada vez con más
frecuencia la más grande fue en el año
2003 no sé si ustedes se acuerdan fue
terrible murieron más de 15.000 personas
en ese momento justamente se creó el
organismo que prepara a la sociedad para
las famosas canículas que es cuando la
temperatura no cambia entre el día y la
noche que es lo grave sobre todo para
las personas mayores luego ha habido
episodios todos 2015 16 17 y 18 y este
año las temperaturas aquí en parís
llegaron a 40 y 26 grados celsius
increíble porque pensemos que francia
está en el centro de europa no está en
el sur sobre todo parís está casi casi
al norte entonces no es una temperatura
obviamente habitual para este tipo de
ciudad